[Music]
you're gonna love this so um
whitney cummings was on joe rogan's show
and uh well i'll just show you there's
cash that's true
into it there's teachers making action
and we don't pay teachers enough if
teachers go on only fans and show their
tits like
i know but isn't that like sad
isn't it sad to make 30 grand a year it
is sad when you're teaching our next
generation yeah but what i'm saying is
isn't it sad that that's how they have
to make money
i mean
yeah i guess it's it's it depends i just
watched this have you seen this
documentary the most hated man on the
internet
no
who is the most hated man on the
internet his name is hunter moore i
don't know brandon shaw just went like
this
ah
i saw that
and i [ __ ] i mean
i mean
look it's not like
a complete there's a little more oh no
it's not that bad no i don't want to say
joey i don't want to i don't want to
over sell it from you yeah it's not that
bad it's just chopped
think it's just a big deal because it's
the first time he's just said he broke
the silence and by the way
i honestly was when i saw the title i
thought whitney cummings was going to
bring something up
because she's had her little run-ins
brittany cummings would rick something
was going to break something up but
rogan she wasn't even talking about
brendan and rogan's like
and by the way you know why he said that
there is a documentary
there's a documentary that has that
title the most hated man
when we watch the one we watched that's
why when i first heard it i was like oh
okay so he probably so rogan saw that
we have our you know that we have our
clips from a couple of those brenden
dogs pretty funny yeah
i remember this guy
look
whitney is literally she's like i don't
want to be in this clip no it's funny
you say that
watch watch
watch watch watch
[Laughter]
by the way i don't like whitney cummings
but i'm just bringing this up that this
is a funny
objectively funny can i be honest yeah
it's the jokes aren't even that mean no
but the amount of laughter says a lot
the laughter's worse to the jokes worse
than the joke
well it's funny you said that because
this is like this is like
a bunch of bottled up
i've been waiting to laugh at this [ __ ]
on camera for a long time
okay check it out check out how to check
it out
i don't even want to get caught in these
crosstails i don't even want to be close
to this it's what you it's easy by the
way merch hadn't seen this because i i
was playing while he was on the phone
president i'm funny it was god of these
crosshairs i don't want to be i don't
want to be around anymore
bro
okay i'm sorry i don't know okay if it's
annoying i'm going to play rogan
laughing again because like you said
merch you nailed it that the last
thing's worth is worse than any joke he
said isn't it sad that that's how they
have to make money
i mean
yeah i guess it's it's it depends i just
watched this have you seen this
documentary the most hated man on the
internet no
dude who is the most hated man on the
internet his name is hunter moore i
don't know brandon job just went like
this
[Laughter]
i don't even want to get caught in these
crosshairs i don't even
want to be close to this
damn it there was a child
[Applause]
oh that was close
oh gosh
by the way god damn it andrew i just did
andrew schultz's podcast i did a bunch
of podcasts in uh in new york and it was
always like the countdown to when that
was gonna come up right i'm glad we just
got out of the way real early okay
listen i love brendan i love him he's my
homie he's always going to be my i don't
care what dumb [ __ ] he says dude i don't
give a [ __ ] i love that guy to death
ride or die and i agree that rogan is
right or died but when you say something
like i don't care what a dumb [ __ ] he
says
look
people should look and we're mad at
rogan for creating him and i get it but
again
i i want to be fair here and say this i
also see it from the
take the comic thing out of him and like
the friend that the guy aspect of where
you're like yeah man he's kind of a
[ __ ] but he's my boy like what are you
gonna do you know what i mean like what
are you gonna do you know wait unless he
like [ __ ] molests a kid right right
or
i get that man that was a [ __ ] genuine
someone brought it up in the chat a
genuine deep laugh